jetzt kommt das auf dass die Menschheit
seitdem Piedro Lombardi DSDS gewonnen
hat wartet das Fragen Lotto mit ihm wie
wird er diese Herausforderung meistern
auch wir waren nicht ganz sicher was wir
ihn fragen können und was nicht auf
jeden Fall ich glaube es wird ziemlich
lustig pass auf das ist das Fragenlotto
da sind gemeine Fragen und harmlose
Fragen drin du kannst selber entscheiden
ob du lieber gemeine oder harmlose
Fragen ziehen willst und du musst S auch
nicht beantworten kannst ja aussuchen
dann nehme ich lieber eine harmlose fr
ja bitte Greif rein so zwei drei musst
du schon ziehen vielleicht auch eine
rote mal
also zwei Fragen okay okay okay aufm ja
einfach so
abdrehen was heißt das geschmackssicher
die Auswahl deiner Klamotten ist sehr
geschmackssicher also gut
äh ja war das immer schon so und jetzt
kannst du mir antworten also also ja
meine Geschmacksrichtung von Klamotten
war halt immer eigener Stil ich bin sehr
gern bunt angezogen wie man auch sieht
und nie so elegant ist nicht so mein Typ
und er sportlich Ding so so eine coole
Jacke paar Ketten cppy ja war immer so
war immer so sehr gut super eine rote ja
die
rein wenn die jetzt gemein ist ne ich
antw gemein egal ich antworte alles
auchin kommt drauf
an mal gucken ich weiß gar nicht
mehr was ich kann jetzt wenn es mir ein
bisschen findest du nicht auch dass
deine erste Single totaler
popinheitsbrei ist was ist das auch so
mainstreamige glatte
harmlose also das geht jetzt an die
Musik also ich finde den Song Hammer und
wenn er dir nicht gefällt tut mir leid
für dich gut okay komm dann zieh noch
eine grüne oder rote eine grüne
natürlich ja
okay
so das Video ist ja vor allen Dingen
sensationell stimmt wie lange habt ihr
da gedreht Tag
ähm 11 Stunden 11 Stunden ja was ist
dein Geheimnis deines Erfolges ja ich
habe da kein großes Geheimnis also
ähm das wichtigste ist einfach dass du
immer alles gibst immer
äh konsequent an deiner Sache arbeitest
und das ist das Geheimnis also immer
wenn du ein Traum hast an deinem Traum
arbeiten und dran bleiben das ist mein
Geheimnis gut dann wünsche ich dir viel
Erfolg vor allen Dingen beim dran
bleiben okay auf jeden Fall super vielen
Dank dass du da warst vielen Dank dass
ich da sein
durfte